This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
[music] diagnose, treat, cure, or
prevent any diseases. nor is it intended
to take the place of your primary care
physician. The statements in this
program have not been evaluated by the
[music] FDA. Testimonials are shared as
individual experiences of the
individual. Results vary and may not be
typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health [music] or income. As
an empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to [music] share the teachings
of a founding father of the science of
epigenetics. Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor [music] of Science in Plant and
Soil Sciences, Doctor of Veterary
Medicine, Ford Post-Do and Pathology,
Naturopathic Doctor
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended
>> Hello everyone and welcome to a very
special edition of Daily with Doc and
Becca. And there's no Doc here today.
There's no Becca here today,
but we do have a very special guest who
I will be bringing on the screen in just
a little bit. Uh my name's Coach AJ and
I'm filling in for Becca Dukes today
who's traveling and we have um our
audience. Thank you for uh being with us
on Rumble and Facebook and YouTube and
and uh X and um uh everywhere else that
you are watching the show. Thank you
very much.
Uh I am um pleased to have Jonathan Eard
with us. Jonathan is a constitutional
attorney is I'm hoping that is a good
terminology to describe him as, but he's
certainly a gentleman who has um worked
his way through uh many courts. He's um
a prolific writer uh and he is a big
friend to longevity. Uh my introduction
doesn't do him any justice, but I'd love
to bring him on the screen. Jonathan
Eort. Everybody welcome uh in uh join me
in welcoming
uh Jonathan Eort to the screen.
Jonathan, thank you for being with us on
Daily with Doc today.
>> Thank thanks for taking your time out of
your day. I know that you squeeze you
squeeze us in amongst a lot of uh thing
other things that you had going on. So,
I really appreciate you you're joining
us.
>> You're welcome.
Thank you. So, um, where to start with
you? Um,
you know, you have worked with Dr. Joel
Wallak. Uh, you've known him for many
years. Tell us a little bit about how
you met Dr. Wallak.
>> Well, I believe I first became uh
familiar with Dr. Wallak in the early
1990s.
So I I it's a little bit hard for me to
remember all the details back then but
uh I was contacted I think by Steve
Wallak maybe by Dr. Wallop directly and
they wanted me to undertake a review of
their their labeling and their you know
compliance with food and drug law. And
then that uh grew into a relationship
that led to many uh actions against the
FDA over the years and a lot of
struggles and a lot of fights with
problems that arose that we overcame. So
it was a good it was a good opportunity
to be at the dragon slayer for for Dr.
Wallak. Um and of course Dr. Wallak is
in is himself a a truly remarkable
pioneer and scientist
uh who is well known throughout the
entire industry for being really at the
forefront of the nutrition revolution in
America.
>> Okay. And and why why you why what what
uh were your credentials at that time
that qualified you as someone to be
sought a sought after to help identify
irregularities in labeling or what what
was your experience at that at that
point? Well, um I think uh most of my
clients at the time hired me because I
was a fighter and most most of the bar
would just lie down and take whatever
the government would dish out without
challenging it. So there's quite a bit
of problems there. You know, the Food
and Drug Administration is notorious for
censoring nutrient disease information,
has for many decades. And uh the bar,
the food and drug bar is oftenimes
comprised of lawyers who don't want to
offend the agency, but rather want to
work with it. I didn't care. I I came uh
from a different entire background. I
came to Washington when I was very
young. I was uh came came into law
school when I was I think 19 uh 18. I
went to undergraduate school at 16. So
16, 17, 18, 19, 20. I was 20 and I got
out of law school at 23. And then I was
hired by the Reagan administration to
work at the Federal Communications
Commission and I was heavily involved
with First Amendment issues there and
the deregulation of radio and and
television. Uh, and then I left the FCC
and went into private practice as a
federal litigator against the
government. So I was litigating on
different issues against the F federal
communications commission and in the
administrative courts and so forth. So I
think what appealed to Dr. Wallock, the
reason why they hired me initially was
that I was probably one of the few
lawyers that actually had sued the
government and then in addition that had
a track record of success in defeating
the government. So in most instances,
probably 98% of the time, uh, the
government prevails in cases brought in
civil courts against the government. U,
but in my career, I've had good fortune,
knock on wood, to, um, beat them over
and over again.
>> Why do you think that is just by not
laying down or knowing your stuff? Or
what do you think that combination might
be?
>> Well, I'm driven by a passion for the
First Amendment, for the Constitution.
Ever since I was a young boy, I've
really loved the American Constitution,
its defense of individual liberty, the
uniqueness of our heritage. Here we are
on the 250th anniversary of the
Declaration of Independence. That is
perhaps the most remarkable political
document in the history of the world.
The second paragraph of the Declaration
of Independence is unique in all the
world. No other nation on earth uh uh
since or before that time uh stated as
its fundamental creed that all men are
created equal. That all are are born
equal and that they are endowed by their
creator by God with certain unalienable
rights. Not government endowed by God
not government. And that among those are
life, liberty and the pursuit of
happiness. And the governments are
instituted among men to protect the
rights of the govern. That's the very
purpose of the government. and that just
governments derive their power, their
just powers from the consent of the
government. Those uh four cardinal
principles of the American republic
exists nowhere else on earth. We are
unique in that regard. That is our
legacy of liberty. But as George
Washington explained, uh we will never
have that liberty to count on unless we
fight for it. We have to continuously
fight for it because it's in the
interests of those who govern to have
more power and to seize power and to
violate rights to pursue their agenda.
So unless we defend our liberties and
fight for them, we will lose them. And
that has been the history of our
country. The remarkable history of our
country is that over and over again
we've expanded the scope of liberty and
defense of liberty. and we have uh
experienced far few instances in which
there's been a contraction of rights and
when there has been we've fought
vigorously against it. That's what
happened with the Food and Drug
Administration. It took on the role of
violating the First Amendment as if it
never had to explain why in the first
place it chose to do so despite the
Constitution. So you can't say anything
about a product affecting a a disease
even if it does, if it's a nutrient,
unless the government preapproves it.
That's called a prior restraint. The
founding fathers prohibited that under
the first amendment. It never should
have come into existence. So I I worked
at the Kato Institute. I was a vice
president of the Kato Institute. I I uh
I wrote a paper called contrived
distinctions, the doctrine of commercial
speech and first amendment
juristprudence that got quite a bit of
circulation. Maybe Dr. Wallik read that.
I don't know. But uh I argued against
the whole paradigm that was uh designed
by the Supreme Court to defend the
expansion of the administrative state
and its violation of ad of of our
rights. In the case of the FDA,
violation of our first amendment rights.
So Dr. Wallak is a strong advocate of
the Constitution. He loves the
Constitution. He's a great American who
believes in the founding principles of
this country. And so we hit it off right
away because that's that's what I'm
about. I've had the good fortune in my
career of choosing who to represent. I
don't represent parties whose whose seek
ends that I disagree with. I just don't
do it. So I've had the privilege of
representing parties that fight for
liberty and that gives me the chance to
fight in the courtroom for them. And
that's what I've done for over 42 years.
when you say liberty. So, um my you know
I I I've heard and by the way I I have
uh
uh seen uh people like Ron Paul respect
your intellect and your uh tact. Uh but
um when you say the word liberty, do you
uh are you referring to
um my right to do anything
lawful or my right to do anything lawful
that does not infringe on someone else's
right? In other words, if I had a
finding and I honestly believed that
um
toenail lint could um heal a disease. Is
is it my right if I really believe that
to talk about that? I mean what what's
your thought? Or is it just based on
science? I mean what's the what is li
what is
what does liberty allow me to say?
>> So uh Thomas Jefferson gave us the
American definition of liberty. Um he
wrote to Isaac Tiffany in 18uh
and he said uh rightful liberty is
unobstructed action according to will
within limits drawn around us by the
equal rights of others. He said, 'I did
not say within the limits of the law
because the law is often but the
tyrant's will and always so when it
violates the rights of an individual.
That is the uh most beautiful definition
for that term liberty and the most
accurate definition of liberty within
the American system of juristprudence.
So what does it mean? Does it mean that
you can commit fraud? No, because you're
violating the rights of someone else.
You can't defraud someone by trying to
sell them something that doesn't do at
all what you say it does. But by the
same token, um, under our first
amendment, remember the first amendment
deprivives this the government, as James
Madison explained in the first congress,
it deprivives the government of any
power whatsoever over speech and press.
It just denies the government the power
to regulate or or pass legislation to
block it. And does that mean that all
speech is protected? No. Why? Because if
speech is used as a weapon to deprive
another person of their rights or of
their equal rights, then that speech is
actionable. So, for example, if I cry
fire in a crowded theater, I've just uh
violated your right because I've caused
a stampede. people are taking away your
liberty and your maybe your life uh by
their actions in response to my false
fraudulent statement that there's a fire
in the theater when there isn't. So that
then is actionable against me. Did I
speak? Yes, I said fire. Uh what
motivated me is irrelevant because my
speech became a weapon. In fact, when
speech merges with action, it is then
actionable against by the government.
But uh most questions dealing with the
government uh do not necessarily have to
involve speech. So we look at actions,
right? So we look at um the product that
you're producing and we ask the
question, what foundation do you have
for that uh um product? But that
question is not the appropriate question
of government. Why? Because the burden
of proof
under the first amendment is against the
government. The government has to prove
your statement is false. You don't have
to prove your statement is true.
Interesting, right? What that means is
that the whole system for regulation of
speech by the FDA and by the FTC is
unconstitutional
because in every instance the
administrative agencies don't start
their action based on proof that what
you said was false.
They start their action by demanding
that you prove your statement true. Not
only just true based on what reasonable
people would conclude, but true to a
conclusive degree and conclusivity in
matters of speech is almost impossible
because speech is evolutionary and
because speech is subject to debate.
Almost any proposition you make in
politics, law, science,
uh is going to be open to debate. Does
that mean that you should be deprived of
your speech unless the only things you
have to say the limiting the only things
you have to say to those that are
conclusively true? No. Under the First
Amendment, the burden of proof is on the
government to prove definitively that
what you said was false. Not only that,
it shouldn't be actionable unless it
causes injury. If you tell me a lie and
it has of is of no consequence, why
should you be prosecuted? If you tell me
a lie that induces me to take an action
and caused me injury, then you should be
open to prosecution.
So these are this is the way you
reorient the law to match the framer's
intent, the founding principles that
underly the constitution and our rule of
law in America. Given given that uh
given that interpretation, why then
submit at all to
uh the courts uh or why acquies to their
system if if you think that the system
is
uh is not uh built correctly. Let's say
let's say that
>> the original system is so in other words
Alexander Hamilton in the federalist
papers explained why federal judicial
review is necessary of federal law. Why?
Because we have a system that is a mixed
constitution where each branch of
government has separate powers and that
is to ensure that no single individual
is possessed of both legislative
executive or legislative and judicial or
legislative executive and judicial
power. James Madison defined that in the
federalist papers as the very definition
of tyranny. He relied on on Montescu, a
French philosopher who explained in his
spirit of the laws why there needed to
be a separation of powers in government.
And so why why then do we submit
ourselves to a judiciary or the rule of
law? In other words, because the courts
have to be an ultimate arbiter of
conflicts related to whether the law
applies in a particular case or whether
you have a a legal defense. All of these
things have to be adjudicated under the
constitutional system that we've
developed and I think it's the best
system in the world when it's
appropriately in following the founding
father's intentions.
uh this whole thing um systems for
construction of the constitution I wrote
about in a book called um freedom
technology in the first amendment and
that was my first book uh a billion
years ago 199
or something like that. Um but um there
there is an enormous ideological
foundation
for our concept of liberty and rights.
And the uniqueness of the American
system is that unlike any other place in
the world, you have uh rights that are
from God, not government. So they can't
be taken away by government. So for
example, our members of longevity who
live in Canada, let's take the Canadian
example. In Canada,
your rights are said to come from
parliament. Uh just like that's the
position of the of the English and
British. So when your rights come from
parliament, parliament can choose
circumstances in which those rights can
be taken away. So during the co
epidemic, they took people's rights
away. They took people's rights to
practice their religion away. They took
people's right to speak if they were
critical of the government away. They
took people's rights to go to business
to to work away unless they were
vaccinated. They did all these things.
Similar things were attempted here. But
they they ultimately ran into problems
here because in our courts, unlike in
the Canadian courts, uh we have our
rights independent of what the
government does. In Canada, the courts
simply ask, well, did Parliament uh did
Parliament exercise emergency powers at
the request of the prime minister? Yes.
Did they suspend these rights? Yes.
Well, you have no case. Sorry. You know,
you have to suffer. In this country,
that could not happen. it it they tried
very hard to do it but uh and they took
away several people's rights but
ultimately there was vindication in the
courts and our system uh returned to to
protect the sovereignty of the American
people in our country uniquely in all
the world we are sovereign we are the
power source of power when government uh
falls you know uh violates the
constitution it presumes itself through
the individuals in government to possess
sovereignty that We don't have that's
not true. Everything in government does
must be by representation
or subject to limitations if not by
representation that are strictly
designed to limit the powers of those
who are in government. We have what's we
have a written constitution which is it
was first unique to the United States
when it was adopted in 1787 when it was
proposed in 1787 adopted in 1791.
It it's unique because it was written,
but also it was unique in that no powers
exist in the federal government except
those expressly contained in the
constitution.
All other powers are reserved to the
states. All other all rights that are
not articulated in the bill of rights
are reserved to the people under the 9th
and 10th amendments to the constitution.
So, it's truly we we really in this
250th year of the Declaration of
Independence, we should all be
celebrating like, you know, we should be
thanking ourselves, our our country over
and over and over again for the great
privilege of being born into a country
that is that stands for principles that
are based on the protection of our
rights.
It's remarkable and people take it for
granted.
And a lot of people because they take it
for granted
uh ignore its significance until they go
into another country, try to live in
another country. And you'll soon
discover that over time, even even in a
friendly European country, that it's
nowhere like this place when it comes to
your freedom to speak or your rights uh
and your right to property and your
right to do with your own property what
you would. Not that that is always
protected here, but it certainly isn't
protected in Europe. So it's, you know,
I I that's why I I am why I do what I do
because that's my obsession. My
obsession is the Constitution of the
United States, the intellectual
principles that underlly the
Constitution. I've spent my whole life
studying it uh and and deep digging
deeper and deeper and deeper into its
roots and mastering the uh wisdom that
came from these people. The founding
fathers truly were uh unique people,
remarkable
in their command of rights theory which
was new. Uh the rights movement arose in
opposition to the Hannavarian kings in
England in the in the late uh 1600s and
then into the 1700s. It was the
reputation of the divine right of kings.
uh and it arose because of John Lock's
second treatise on government in part
but also before that time during the
divine under the divine right of kings
only the king has rights and you may
have rights by leave of the king but the
king is God's emissary on earth and he
possesses all rights well that in that
system you're just a a slave the
interesting thing is the the roots and
expansion of slavery is entirely ly
predicated upon deprivation of rights of
course but once you make this remarkable
proposition as in the second paragraph
of the declaration of independence the
reason why it's earthshattering quite
literally is that Thomas Jefferson took
the position that all men are created
equal did he mean by that only men no
understanding both in the second
treatise on government and at the time
Jefferson wrote it was that men meant
people and did he mean it only to apply
to white people as is often times said
by revisionists in their history. No.
And how do we know that? Because there
was a 134
word paragraph in his original draft of
the Declaration of Independence in which
he condemned George III for bringing the
institution of slavery to America and
said that slavery was an abomination and
deprivation of rights. So when he said
all men are created equal, he was quite
literally saying all men. Now isn't that
strange for someone who owned slaves? It
is. But is that uh uh um show shows that
there is an aspiration
to a better world. And even all of the
founding fathers, Thomas Jefferson
included,
condemned the institution of slavery
even when they had slaves. And you ask
yourself, well, how can that be? Because
the economy, the world in which they
live, created by George III, was a world
in which agriculture could not be ever
profitable without human bondage,
without slave labor. If you liberated
all of your slaves and you were a large
plantation owner, you would suffer
massive debt. And most of the founding
fathers did by the time they died. But
when they died, they they manumented or
freed their slaves because in when for
example when George Washington died,
Martha was still living. And he wrote in
his will that all the slaves would be
manumented when Martha died because he
knew if he manumented them at his death
and she still lived for many years after
that she would be absolutely uh uh
povertystricken and would go bankrupt.
And he didn't want that to happen. But
he knew slavery was wrong and so he had
it had it all manumented. Is this an
imperfect world? Yes.
>> Yeah. That's that's it's a little
imperfect because you know my my my
rights end where my rights end where
when yours are impinged upon. But um so
but I I'm with you Jonathan. I I do
understand what you're saying. No one is
perfect. Um
and um you know you've given us a ton of
food for thought already. But back to
our friends and this is our 30th year at
Youngevity. So, uh, you know, being
being a a a
decade birthday
in time with America, I guess there's
something uh slightly at least poetic
about that. Um
Jonathan, what why
what is the significance as far as the
science goes if you understand and
clearly you do because you wouldn't have
been able to articulate it if you
didn't. Uh what is the benefit of folic
acid
and why now do you have influencers
who are beating up folic acid when it
has saved so many and save suffering
from so many more.
Please explain to us what the
significance
and the need to have folate, folic acid,
and if there's a difference, what that
difference might be, and the
significance in um congenital um
the how does it benefit human life?
>> So, um I'm not a scientist. Uh Dr.
Wallak is Dr. Wallet could give you the
best explanation, but I can tell you
this. Uh, so
one of the primary claims that we first
sued the Food and Drug Administration
over
um included the folic acid neural tube
defect claim. We had a claim that 800
micrograms of folic acid taken by women
of childbearing age before they become
pregnant, before they become pregnant.
Absolutely critical.
reduces the risk of having a neural tube
defect birth that is spinoipida or
anphille
by as much as 80%. And what is that?
That's when a baby is born with a spinal
cord outside of their spinal cavity
there or when their brain is outside of
their skull.
Now the babies born like that would
oftenimes die but when they didn't die
they would have uh oftentimes horrific
existences where they would have to go
through surgery after surgery after
surgery and would for the rest of their
lives be limited in their in what they
could do and then also they would
frequently die before they reached old
age. They would die in their 20s or 30s.
It's really um a horrible birth defect,
but it's preventable. And folic acid
deficiency is the causitive reason for
um for the disease. So you ask yourself,
um why then did the federal government
suppress it, deny it, uh the right to
communicate that? It's true. It's
provable. The CDC was telling doctors to
do tell patients about this. And yet the
FDA refused to allow it on the label or
in the labeling of folic acid
supplements. So we sued FDA over that
and we presented massive amount of
evidence supporting the proposition
scientifically. The government really
didn't argue that the science was
mistaken. What the government said uh
and it's driven by protection for the
drug industry. It didn't want people at
that time. This is a novel situation. It
was in the Pearson versus Shala case.
Never before was FDA's censorship power
questioned under the first amendment as
it was in this case. But they they
didn't argue to the court that they
censored it because uh they were
complying with the first amendment. They
said that the first amendment doesn't
apply to the FDA. They said the FDA's
regulatory scheme is so complex that
only uh brilliant scientists at the FDA
can decide for the rest of us what
science we can have and what we can't
have. And if they give us access to
information before we're mature enough
in our education to understand it, we're
we will abuse it. So they said if you
let people know that folic acid might
reduce the risk of neural tube defect
births, they might consume mass
quantities of folic acid. They said if
they did that they might suffer from a
vitamin B12 deficiency that would be
masked in in uh drug testing or blood
testing uh because the folic acid would
mask it. So they said we're going to
we're going to create uh B12 deficiency
situations because people will be eating
all this folic acid and it'll it'll hide
from doctors the B12 deficiency. So that
was of course ridiculous a set of
arguments and um when I argued this
before the court of appeals in the DC
circuit uh they they they vigorously
attacked the Justice Department attorney
uh and and expressed their their that
they weren't persuaded at all that the
First Amendment doesn't apply to the FDA
or that the American people are too
stupid to understand science or uh I
remember uh Patricia Wald called one of
the three, she was brilliant, one of the
three judges on the panel saying, um,
you know, I shop at Whole Foods and when
I go to the Whole Foods aisle that has
all these vitamins and minerals and so
forth in it, um, some of the most
sophisticated consumers in the food
market are in that aisle.
She said, "I don't see that these people
are stupid. They're asking rather
sophisticated questions and it shows me
that they're fully capable of
comprehending what we're hearing about
today. And I don't understand why when
you put on a label that 800 micrograms
of folic acid could reduce the risk of a
neural tube defect birth by as much as
80%. That that's somehow too complicated
for women to understand. So anyway, we
won the thing um because regardless of
whether the public understands truth, uh
truth is fully protected under the first
amendment. I don't have to speak simply
uh to to you know have a government
sensor tell us you you must break down
your speak speech into very simple terms
if you wish to communicate to the
public. No, that's not what the first
amendment is about. It's to end
censorship. Again, no power whatsoever
over speech and press. So um the court
agreed and said that the FDA had to
favor disclosure over suppression. It
held its whole health claims review
process unconstitutional
and it created what was called the
qualified claims process uh directly as
by order uh under the first amendment.
No statute existed for it. So you would
the government would have to allow any
claim that is scientifically backed to
be communicated to the public. Uh if it
could be rendered non-misleading with a
qualification.
The government could claim uh speech was
not approved. They could even put that
in there. The government could say that
the uh speech it disagrees with it to a
degree, but it would have to state um uh
these things as a qualification. and it
could not deny the public access to that
information at the point of sale. So
that was the the court's decision. It
was a landmark decision and it overthrew
a whole regime of censorship that the
FDA had spent the better part of uh
three decades constructing in detail. Uh
and they blew blew their minds. So for
the better part of another half decade,
they fought me in court over and over
and over again, losing over and over and
over over again um to try to keep that
old system in place completely trying to
ignore, undermine and prevent adoption
of this system. Why? Because the FDA is
a pathy for the drug industry.
The drug industry does not want
competition,
even competition from people
understanding what elements and foods
and nutrients can do to reduce disease
or treat disease. They don't they only
want you to think that for disease, you
got to go to the doctor. And when you go
to the doctor, you need to get a pill.
And that's the drug that they get
approved by FDA.
Now, that system has failed miserably. I
mean, if we'd look at the statistics, I
have them right here. I was on George
Nory the other night and we went through
this.
>> We heard
>> and
but uh I think it's shocking this system
has failed so miserably when you look at
uh this is all from the CDC. By the way,
in 2023, 76.4%
194 million Americans reported having
one or more chronic conditions.
76.4% of the American population, 194
million people, have one or more chronic
conditions. 59.5%
of young people, 18 to 34, have one or
more chronic conditions. 78.4%
of people in their midlife years, 35 to
64,
have one or more chronic conditions. 93%
of older adults, 65 and older, have one
or more chronic conditions. So it's six
and 10 young people, 8 and 10 people in
their middleage years, 9 and 10 older
adults.
And uh these chronic conditions are
heart disease, cancer, stroke, and
diabetes. They are all nutrition related
diseases. They're all the result of
eating the wrong things
and
>> eating the wrong things and and not
putting the right things in.
>> Right. And over the past 20 years, the
prevalence of chronic disease in America
has increased every year. Every single
year. No change in the trajectory.
Despite all the drugs that have been
approved, despite all and we've had
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
drugs approved a year for these
conditions and we've not had any change.
In 2016, the total direct health care
cost to the US to treat chronic disease
was $1.1 trillion.
And three in four Americans have at
least one chronic condition that had to
be treated. Three and four. Four out of
every five Americans is taking some
psychiatric treatment,
uh, some psychiatric drug.
That's blows your mind away, doesn't it?
I mean, that's enough to make you want
to take a psychiatric drug. But the
point the point is, I mean, 65 to 70% of
adult Americans are taking at least one
prescription drug. 65 to 70% are taking
one prescription drug.
So, uh, you know, the it's just it goes
on and on. I mean, we spend $15,474
per capita on health care in the United
States. Per person. every person per
capita, we're spending $15,747.
Uh and and uh um that's the highest in
the world by far. And yet the h health
outcomes are are abysmal. So the average
life expectancy in America is 79 years.
That's 50th in the world behind Japan,
Switzerland, and most of Western Europe.
And the US spends the highest in the
world on health care. 16.9% of our GDP
is spent on healthcare. And we're 68th
in the world in healthy life expectancy.
So the rest of the world lives healthier
longer than we do. Just about 65 60
we're 68th in health life expectancy.
This is according to America's health
ranking system. Um you know these are in
other words the whole system of modern
medicine has utterly failed
in the most important areas
and that means we need a new paradigm
and that new paradigm really is one that
must be driven by it must be patient
centric and it must be driven by the
patient receiving full information at
the point of sale in the market. It has
to be a preventive model, not an
emergency intervention model. The way
ever since World War II, we've had a
alipathic medical system that is focused
on emergency intervention. So you you
you don't go to the doctor to to prevent
disease. He doesn't you never go to the
doctor and and talk about the uh your
diet, exercise and lifestyle
uh annually to say what do I need to do
to tinker here and tinker there to get
it better to get it better to get it
better so that I won't develop these
diseases.
No, we go along merrily and and get the
diseases and then once we have the the
symptomology of it, we go to the doctor
and then they give us a treatment that
is not really a treatment in most
instances. It just masks the symptoms
and we get sicker and sicker and sicker
and then we die earlier and we have
longer periods of time when we're
unhealthy. That doesn't have to be. And
Secretary Kennedy has dedicated the
administration to ending the chronic
disease epidemic in America. But
unfortunately, the FDA is not doing
anywhere near what it needs to do to
bring about that end of chronic disease.
The only way it's going to end is if we
get information at the point of sale. So
we can have all this information about
what nutrients and food do available to
us so we can make the decisions. We need
debate in that marketplace open so that
the government doesn't censor
everything. We need open free market and
ideas information so that when when a
mother's going to buy something for a
child at the grocery store, she's able
to say, "Okay, this child's this age. I
should really be focusing on omega-3s
and these other substances to make that
sure that that child selenium and other
things. Make sure that child has what it
needs in order to develop properly."
That's not what the the typical person's
doing when they're going to the grocery
store. They're that what are they
asking? The typical person going to the
grocery store isn't asking what foods do
I need to eat in order to maximize
health outcomes. They're not asking that
question. What they're asking is what
tastes good. But Jonathan, even the
people who are intentionally looking to
eat vegetables of all colors and uh
trying to uh what they've been told and
even by the new food pyramid, uh these
folks are making the attempt. Uh but our
country doesn't have the quality of soil
to produce uh the the the nutritious
food that we think that we're getting.
>> So this is what Dr. Wallak taught us and
this is what I forget the name of the
doctor that he relied upon who was an
agricultural scientist
u but uh uh you know he he was way ahead
of his time right he was speaking about
these things in the 70s and 80s and that
the that the that the soil was depleted
of nutrients because of modern pra uh
there it is Dr. William Albert um uh
that um the soil was depleted of
nutrients. Thank you, Albert. And that,
you know, as a result,
a tomato doesn't taste like a tomato did
in 1930 in in 2026.
Uh the reason is that there's a
completely different uh nature to the
soil and to farming techniques and and
that has changed to a degree with
regenerative farming. But there it's all
you know big pharma has kind of co-opted
the term regenerative
uh in instances where it actually is not
regenerative farming and by regenerative
farming I mean to to treat the soil with
nutrients and with substances that will
decay into nutrients
and to develop it well with all sorts of
things that that are animal-based and
plant-based and and uh and even insects
And then to develop plants in an in a
local environment in which you are
maximizing nutritional outcomes in in
the fruit of the plant. So that when you
harvest this and you bring it to market
promptly, then the person who consumes
it is getting the maximum amount of
folic acid is getting the B vitamins and
C and so on rather than getting
something that is just a hollow shell
essentially
>> devoid. Yeah. Most of it.
>> Yeah. and and and and that's that's
beyond our control, but it wouldn't be
if we were fully educated. If if we went
to the grocery store and we knew that
this tomato, which is mass- prodduced or
hydroponic or whatever, has this
percentage of the these specific
nutrients, and we could compare it to a
locally grown organic regenerative
farming product that has a different
nutritional profile with more nutrients
in it. we'd at least be able to say,
"Well, I don't want that plastic thing.
I want this."
>> But that's novel. So, you think we
should label uh nutritional content on
our on our fruits and vegetables?
>> Oh, yeah. And this is not possible. It
it is possible, but it's not possible to
make the claims that should come out of
this so that we can distinguish, you
know, that says, "Hey, this has more
lycopine in it than even your, you know,
your typical uh tomato. it's a
concentrated lycopine product and it and
it has anti-cancer effects. You can't
say that. But if you could, you know, if
you've had a family history of some of
of one kind of cancer or another and you
want to maximize immune function and
diminish the risk of cancer to avoid the
necessity of, you know, some type of
surgical intervention, you would say,
okay, well, you know what? Our family
has this history. I'm going to do what I
think is best to reduce the risk of
cancer. I'm not going to buy that
product with a low lycopine percentage
in it. I'm going to buy this one with a
high percentage. And I'm going to also
get the information at the point of sale
about uh the cancer risk reduction
effect. This one that has the the
trigger point for lycopine to reduce the
risk of cancer. It has the quantitative
amount per serving. It'll be able to say
that. And so that requires the
government to get out of the censorship
business. I mean, if you went to the the
if you if you went online to buy a
nutritional product or whatever and you
were you were given full information,
[clears throat] sure there'd be
problems. There always a problems or
somebody's going to be fraudulent,
whatever. But then there's all this
prosecution that happens both private
and public against fraud and it's always
going to happen. but you'd be far more
informed and more interested in buying a
product that would meet a nutritional
profile that would be best for you. And
then your health care practitioners
would speak to this, too. They'd say
they'd they'd be forced into it. They'd
be forced into saying, "Okay, I'm not
going to I could recommend for you this
drug, but as you found out for yourself,
your type 2 diabetes can be controlled
and completely eliminated by dietary
modifications.
Okay, let's talk about that. What are
you eating? Okay. Yeah. Well, I would
suggest this product,
you know, that's what it would break
down. So, it would force uh uh the
alipathic medical model into the
integrative medicine model where doctors
would no longer be talking about crisis
management. They'd be talking about
everyday interventions that you can use
to reduce your risk of disease or if you
have a disease to reduce the severity of
it or maybe even eliminate it like type
two diabetes in its entirety.
And this requires a whole change and
this and this has to be the FDA
changing. And by the way, the whole
administrative state, truth be told, is
unconstitutional. There's no provision
in the constitution to delegate the
power of the legislature or the
judiciary or the executive branch to an
independent repository. In fact, like we
said before, the very uh notion of that
delegation, James Madison said, was the
very definition of tyranny. We have an
agency, the Food and Drug
Administration, typical of over 250
different agencies of the government.
And it has combined legislative and
executive power
and and that's unconstitutional under
the non-legation doctrine which was at
the heart of what the founding fathers
believed in. The Congress has to answer
for everything. We elect them to do
that. They can't delegate away their
power to uh some people we don't elect
and who are not answerable to us to make
these profound decisions that affect the
economy massively that affect our
health, our lives that
>> What about our monetary system?
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. Total disaster.
>> Just checking. Just checking.
>> Um Phyllis
Andy, I'm gonna bring you on the screen.
What kind of question do you have for
our knowledgeable friend?
>> Well, first, uh, this is truly a
revolutionary topic and very timely. Uh,
I know we all appreciate it so much what
you're passing along. Uh, Sandois on
Rumble says, "I love to hear these
constitutional sovereignty topics." and
Olga on YouTube says, "Government exists
to punish the evildoers, which sadly is
no longer the case." Uh, we've got a
question from Ivonne on YouTube. She
asks, "What can we do to help on our
side take away the FDA's power to remove
nutritional supplements from the
market?"
So it's a very timely question because
something has actually been done that is
quite remarkable. at the end of February
of this year, um scientists,
uh political certain political people,
um business people in the nutrition
space, uh and also in the healthc care,
uh space, physicians and scientists all
met in Phoenix, Arizona
uh for a 3-day conference. We were
present there. Um I'm I'm the general
counsel of the Alliance for Natural
Health. Dr. Robert Verkirk, it's a
really brilliant nutrition scientist and
environmental scientist is the head of
the Alliance for Natural Health. They
sponsored the event and we it was uh um
portions of it were in secret so that
these corporations could explain to us
the adverse effects that they were
experiencing from government from
government regulations and what they
would do in the absence of this
censorship and how much information they
would put out all that sort of thing.
Anyway, the upshot of it was a consensus
statement that's truly remarkable. You
can see it at arizonaastatement.org.
Um I would urge everybody, it's free of
charge, to sign up in favor of it, to
endorse it. What why is that important?
As you'll see it when you read this
statement. Um it explains the principles
that we've been talking about today.
uh the constitutional principles and
then it explains specific actions that
need to be taken all across the board to
align the law with those principles and
make us sovereign again in health
freedom and enable us to control our own
biological destinies and have enough
information to do it without government
interference or suppression. So by
signing this thing, you are enabling us
to produce what we hope will be over a
million signatures that will then use in
in persuading members of Congress and
the White House
to adopt the specific reforms that we're
talking about.
And [clears throat] those reforms will
free us. Um now is this the only thing
that we need to do? No. We're going to
have to sue as well. We are we're suing
the government right now in multiple
cases in an effort to expand our freedom
and protect it and expand our rights uh
protection in these areas. But this
statement is once you read it you'll say
wow that thing is truly remarkable. Um
Verkerk and I wrote the statement and we
but it was a consensus statement. all
the scientists, all the business people,
all of the particular um people who are
physicians and others who are involved
in this integrative medicine, all that
who are at the event all agreed
unanimously agreed to the principles and
to the actions.
So, I would urge everybody to sign it. I
go on that web page. It's uh
arizonaastatement.org.
um read the thing. If you agree with it,
sign, you know, sign your name to it.
There are already I think over 10,000
people have signed it. We haven't
promoted it. It's [clears throat] just
word of mouth from the group that was
there and then also, you know, uh some
public appearances that we've made, but
I think the more people we tell about
this and the larger the universe, we
want to get a million signatures. We
want to be able to go into members of
Congress and say, "Hey, look, this is,
you know, there are million people,
there are x number of people in your
jurisdiction, your state or your
district who signed on to this and want
to see this to happen. We want to see if
you'll sponsor or co-sponsor this bill
to help do that to take away the FDA's
power to censor or whatever to expand
the universe of available integrative
health care modalities, innovation and
medicine, ending the monopoly, the drug
monopoly in this country over uh both
health information and access to the
market.
>> [clears throat]
>> So if we do that, we will have the tools
necessary to end the chronic disease
epidemic in America and only if we do
that. But it's that kind of massive
reform that is it's going to take. And
thus far though, Secretary Kennedy has
clearly made his position uh in favor of
this idea of ending the chronic disease
epidemic in America apparent. Um,
unfortunately, uh, the FDA commissioner
McCary has not done anything to
seriously advance the ball on that and
it's been a big disappointment. That's
why we need to do this.
>> One more uh quick comment from uh Green
Bear on
>> I'd like to say something too when
you're done there. Forgive me. a green
bear on Rumble uh refers to our right to
use the products of nature such as
plants and he refers to Genesis 1 28-29
called sometimes the cultural mandate
which refers to our stewardship
um to over nature on this planet. Um,
Andy, real quick.
>> Well, this episode, this interview with
you is so important.
I would like to see Young make this
available on a DVD
and the entire customer base gets a copy
of it. You have covered so beautifully
the Constitution, which is a favorite
subject of mine that came about years
ago when I had to sue the Internal
Revenue Service. And boy did the
Constitution come alive. I beat them by
the way. The Justice Department had to
pay my legal costs.
But Youngevity needs to take this
episode and when people buy products in
some way, no cost, and get this
information that you just put together.
This is talk about the founding fathers
and their brilliance. So is this
interview with you. I am so enjoying
what I'm hearing and this can't be lost
uh with all all the other promotions and
merchandising and and and all that goes
with business in general. I want to see
Youngevity make this available to all of
our customer base.
Jonath Jonathan, in case you didn't
know, Andy was instrumental in making
sure that Doc uh and the and Dead
Doctors Don't Lie got syndicated in in
in different markets. So, it's it's it's
uh Andy who uh was uh the spearhead of
getting hundreds of different stations
to air Dead Doctors Don't Lie.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. that uh dead doctors don't lie is
one of the most remarkable things in our
history because no one ever spoke like
that. Dr. Wallock spoke plainly directly
and explained why you can't trust this
alipathic system, why you can't go to
the doctor and trust them uh to give you
the right information. And the reason
was that really and from my vantage
point was very clear. You know a doctor,
this is how a doctor operates. This is
the universe a doctor operates in.
A doctor cannot give you any advice even
if he thinks it's in your best health
interest if it's going to be
secondguessed by Medicare or by his
fellow practitioners or by the medical
board. What does this really mean? Let
me give you an example. You let's say
you have a heart attack. you go. Let's
say that your heart attack is due in no
small measure because you happen to be
morbidly obese and you have a bunch of
comorbidities that are leading you in
inevitably to a a heart attack that's
going to kill you. And the best thing
that the doctor could do is not just
give you a standard uh one-sizefits-all
approach on, for example, physical
therapy,
x number of weeks, but to put you on a
program that is holistic. It's going to
change your diet. It's going to give you
an exercise program and it's going to
give you a physical therapy program
that's going to last for years because
it's the it's a massive amount of
transformation you're going to need in
order to survive.
And and that whole thing is not Medicare
covered. Only a small portion of the
physical therapy
and specific drugs, anti-coagulants,
whatever are going to be covered.
the rest of it is not covered. Now, that
that's bad enough, but it's worse
because if I, as a doctor, tell you of
these other things and that you need
more of it and recommend it to you and
prescribe it to you, I cannot bill you
for it, but in addition to not being
able to bill you for it, I've just
committed Medicare fraud.
You say, "It's true. It's not fraud.
You're you're doing what's in the best
interest of the patient." It doesn't
matter. If you deviate from the Medicare
recommended care for a patient, you are
opening yourself up to a challenge for
Medicare fraud. When Medicare goes and
audits your files
and they look, even when you didn't bill
Medicare, if you treated a Medicare
beneficiary and gave them advice that
the government has not approved for the
condition, you open yourself up to being
sued by Medicare and and demanding all
the money Medicare gave you as a
practitioner back to the government.
and and this keeps them in line.
So they don't tell you all these things.
>> They know it. A lot of them know this
stuff. Not all of them are anywhere near
as educated in nutrition as they should
be. But they don't they have no
incentive to be because all they can do
to to be safe for themselves,
>> give you a drug,
>> is to give
>> and do some jumping jacks.
>> Yeah. Is to give you the the the
standardized I'll give you another one.
So, a lot of males have benign
prosthetic hyperlasia and an enlarged
prostate.
All right? I think uh if males live long
enough, every single one of them gets
this or gets prostate cancer. If you
live long enough, you get prostate
cancer. So, anyway, [clears throat] all
right. So um you know maybe maybe that's
just desserts but the point is um the
treatment for for benign prosthetic
hyperlasia
uh is is resection which is surgery that
is absolutely barbaric. Okay and and and
and ruinous to your to the quality of
life of the person. All right you may
even end up with a colostomy bag. You
may end up you know totally ruined.
Okay, that is that is like the primary
treatment modality.
I represented a bunch of uh physicians
who came up this is many many many years
ago with a microwave treatment. What
what they would do is they would stick a
probe in and they would they would fry
your prostate and the frying of the
prostate would reduce its size and then
that would relieve the pressure and
would enable you to pee freely and then
it would also al alleviate all of the
conditions. Okay. So that methodology
didn't involve surgery, didn't involve
uh you having to stay in the hospital
and it was an outpatient procedure. All
right. This is this is something that no
male would want to undergo that trans
you know transurethal resection. You
you'd go for this thing instead. All
right. Well, guess what? Medicare
wouldn't approve it.
So, here I had all this I had all this
information that the baby boomers are
going to be massive in the health care,
you know, demand on the healthcare. All
these males are going to be demanding
the surgery. The surgery costs, you
know, 30,000 $40,000 or more dollars,
probably over 100,000 now. And and the
the uh microwave treatment was $3,000
and in in hospital it was 5,000
something. Outpatient it was 3,000.
They would not approve it at all. They
wouldn't. And I said, "Look, the overall
savings to the government is in the
trillions of dollars. quality of life is
much higher
>> and the quality of life is higher. So
the doctors who are getting a patient in
they learn about this but they can't
make it available to the patients. So
they send them off for this brutal
trans urethral resection
when those patients if they knew they
could have a microwave treatment and
walk in and go out the same day and just
sit in the waiting room for an hour to
see if they had some adverse reaction.
And typically they wouldn't they would
they'd be done as compared as compared
to being in in the hospital for a week
and actually uh being disabled for the
rest of their life. Okay. So so that's
the kind of insanity when you have
government political decisionmaking
ruling medical care and dictating how
doctors behave. Um, I wrote an article
for the KO Institute called Murder by
Medicare, which talks about how
allocation of resources by Medicare and
their choices of what to fund and what
not to fund actually promotes an
environment that encourages death at an
earlier age.
Because all of this nutritional
information we know about is not being
covered or encouraged to be given by
Medicare. It's considered quackery. And
I've represented physicians before this.
the Social Security Administration
because and they were brought to task
not because they charged for the advice.
They gave the advice out for free
>> and they were, you know, that was called
a Medicare abuse. They they they abused
a Medicare patient by not giving them
the FDA the the the Medicare approved
treatment.
Jonathan, and and it's it's interesting
that you went down this this alley of
conversation because my question to you
was going to be, do you think there's an
opportunity for the FDA and the Medicaid
Medicare system to be overhauled or do
we need to do a private intervention is
what needs to happen?
>> Well, [clears throat] that's a that's a
huge question really. Um in the first
instance we do need to overhaul these
systems in the long
>> Is it possible?
>> Yes definitely all these things can be
done. It's just a question of political
will. Most politicians sadly are stupid.
I mean if you can't get a job elsewhere
you become a politician. That's the
typical thing.
>> True. That's not always true. Um you
know many people are motivated for great
reasons to be get into politics. If they
do, if they have sincerity and that
that's their motivation, great. But a
lot of them are charlatans and a lot of
them couldn't care less about whe
whether it's going to help people or
not. That's what shocks me, shocks
Cheryl when we go on Capitol Hill, we go
and meet these guys and my goodness, you
know, they you couldn't you couldn't
keep their attention span for more than
a fraction of a second. They just did
not care. They couldn't care less. And
uh that's not true of all of them. It's
true of a good number of them, however.
and uh it's just not their thing. They
don't care whether you die at 79 or you
die at 102. Couldn't couldn't care less.
Um and you know we but but when people
unite like they can with this this
statement and signing it, it that poses
a political threat. In other words, even
if you don't want to pay attention to
the needs of the American people, if you
read that statement and you see that the
number of people who've endorsed it,
you're suddenly going to say, "I've got
to do something about this."
>> A million people is a number that that
moves the needle.
>> Not necessarily a million, but a million
will. So maybe a hundred thousand will.
But a million, if we can get a million
signatures, that is momentous because
they know that for a million people to
sign there, there've got to be at least
10 times that number that are
sympathetic to the same outcomes, you
know, in the same position. So, it's
it's a powerful way to uh to get uh
politicians attention is to show, you
know, there are two ways of getting a
politician's attention. One is to donate
a huge sum of money.
And you and as a committee of one, you
can then get their be an audience,
right? Or you can you can show that a
huge percentage of their constituency
wants something done.
They they they often times move
snailike, you know, and and they have to
be motivated. And unfortunately,
electroshock therapy is not uh allowed
to be used on members of Congress, but
that they need to have like a cattle
prod type of approach to get them to
move.
Um, and if we, you know, if I, and one
thing that can help them do that is to
see that a whole bunch of people are are
anxious to see them do something
>> because they're always running for
office. They're always running for
office.
>> Term limits. Okay. Uh, I'm gonna I'm
gonna try something risky here. Marilyn,
you have 41 seconds. Go.
>> Why is that risky? Hi, Jonathan. love
love love hearing you speak say I have
an organization that I love it's called
raw farms I've been getting all kinds of
organic food and uh dairy from them and
the manufacturers of food for the last
hundred years have tried to remove all
raw dairy from the markets if there's a
way you could help these people right
now they they are getting attacked again
by the FDA they continually get attacked
by them and I heard them proclaim that
they're not going to back down. They are
being told right now that there's ecoli
from their products in three states by
in nine individuals and they said it's
absolutely false. They said they don't
want to back down. They're not because
they test their own products. They have
their employees. There's been no nothing
in their actual company at all saying
there's anything about E.coli. Is there
a way you could help them? It's called
Raw Farms is the name of the company.
>> Yeah. In fact, I did something years ago
and probably be wise to take it up
again. Um there is a solution to this
problem. So the argument on the federal
level has been oh my goodness uh raw
milk is you know the equivalent of um
drinking uh strontium
you know a radioactive substance. uh as
if we have not uh since virtually the
beginning of of mankind um and husbandry
of animals uh not consumed milk. Um the
argument is is is wrong because
ordinarily as long as the animal is is
wellmaintained the milk as long as it's
fresh and kept refrigerated will
ordinarily be okay. However, um yes,
there are instances when when milk,
whether pasteurized or not, will um have
salmonella. Every year, pasteurized
milk, we have uh thousands of people who
are who suffer from salmonella
uh toxicity because the milk for one
reason or another gets contaminated. But
it's not because it was pasteurized
because all the milk we're talking about
is pasteurized. You rarely hear about
raw milk um having that circumstance.
However, it's possible and it would also
be possible to have ecoli uh bacteria in
pasteurized milk as well as raw milk at
the point of sale. So, how do you solve
this problem? Well, guess what? So, I
told the FDA gave that the facts are
these. It's not just limited to um
pasteurized milk or uh raw milk. It's
also present in pasteurized milk. Here
is all the incidents of salmonella every
year, year after year after year after
year after year. It's all it's all
pasteurized milk. So pasteurization is
not going to ensure a a person uh that
that they won't get salmon oil from
milk. Now what we can do that will
completely eliminate any risk to a
consumer is educate them. We can put a
mandatory labeling requirement that says
that there is a possibility that milk uh
may may uh contain salmonella. It may
also contain other bacteriological
elements that might be harmful to you if
you have a compromised immune system or
if you're otherwise vulnerable to these
things. And um to combat that you can do
self-pasteurization. you can boil the
milk at this temperature for this period
of time before you can cons before you
consume it and that is a uh a protective
uh step that you can take. So full
disclosure with that labeling should be
sufficient. You petition the FDA to do
that
and then uh you you what you're
basically doing is eliminating the big
dairy argument that people are
blindsided getting unpasteurized milk
and suffering from uh salmonila because
you're notifying them up front that
salmonil is possible and if it and in
order to reduce the risk of it you
should boil it and for this period of
time and I forget what the it's a short
period of time you boil it on the stove
um and at a certain temperature and then
it kills all of the salmon.
>> Right now it's like 140 to 160 for 15
minutes.
>> Okay.
>> I'll pass that along.
>> Thank you, Marilyn. You're the bomb. And
um
>> and uh Tom Chenalt says you're a great
woman. Zack, we're going to give you a
couple seconds here because we've
already encroached on Jonathan's time
enough. Zack, go ahead. What you got?
>> Thank you. Wow. What a what wonderful,
empowering, eloquently expressed our
health rights. This knowledge
has helped me. Thank you uh uh Jonathan
Nemore. You're you're you're wonderful
because you you empower us, you inform
us, and I just want you to know that Dr.
Wallock, by you helping him, you're
saving lives, too.
because my wife spoke up
well informed and empowered. She had
seven doctors try to convince her that
she was going to die and she didn't have
chemo after being uh diagnosed with uh
white cell clear cancer of the ovaries.
But she stood up for her rights because
of people like you and Dr. Wallik.
People are alive.
Thank you. Well, you're welcome. Uh Dr.
Wallak is incredible. I I I think it
would be interesting to try to quantify
the number of people over his long
career that he had guided to better
health. Um he's, you know, he's probably
saved literally tens of thousands if not
more people's lives because of his
nutritional recommendations. I mean all
those he spent what 300 364 of 365 days
a year for decade after decade giving
health lectures all across the United
States. Um people people would think gee
only a person who would be uh paid
millions and millions of dollars would
would sacrifice himself to that extent.
And Dr. Wallock did it for zilch. You'd
have to pay to fly him there and put him
up for the night. But he didn't profit
off of this. He did this. This is a
labor of love and sacrifice on his part.
He truly wanted to transform the health
of the American people. That's one of
the things that um drove me to have such
great respect for him. Uh is that he,
you know, there's no one like Dr.
Wallock. He he was passionately
committed to this 24 hours a day, seven
days a week and will be um forever. uh
and the changes that have taken place.
You can I mean it is it is likely that
most people would not understand the
cancer risk reduction effects of
selenium the necessity for 90 nutrients
in in addition to just a a standard
multivitamin to have 90 essential
nutrients that they were essential.
um his whole development of the
nutritional profile based on comparative
pathology studying animals in the first
instance as a vet being in the wilds of
Africa with Marlon Perkins
um and having to come up with solutions
when they lack the drugs available. uh
and then developing nutritional
interventions and then finding comp
through comparative pathology all of
those autopsies that he performed on
people that there were commonalities
between the diseases in certain animals
and those people and that the treatments
that he had developed for the animals
might well affect the same results in
people then testing that out and
establishing it. I mean everything his
whole life was directed in this way of
thinking ever since he cured his own
Tourettes with eating the pellets that
were to be available with all the
nutrients in them for the the boine uh
the cows on his farm. I mean, he's here
he is a little kid and he's he's he's
trying to figure out, well, why is it
that when I eat these pellets,
it it's it's curative. And then he
researches this on his own. The other
thing was anybody who saw his lectures
over the years realized he just really
researched everything. All of his books,
he researched everything and he's
obsessed with it. And it's because this
was his passion, his purpose on this
earth. I think was blessed to be one who
would convey this information. Um and he
did it so very well. Um the whole
company young longevity exists only
because in my view because of Dr.
Wallik. uh he was the driving force
behind the company and built it into an
empire not for his own personal uh
benefit but for the benefit of everybody
else. All these other companies fail mo
mostly because the the motivation really
is personal wealth and so they don't
really care that much. Wallock came in
from the other side and unfortunately I
think he sacrificed so much. He's not
been paid what he should be paid for the
miraculous
benefits that he's conveyed to so many
people. But that was that was his choice
and because of it we benefited. So in
other words, we've all been enriched at
his expense. But that is the only way I
think he could have lived because he was
driven by this. It was a passion for all
his life. It drove him into becoming a
vet. And then it in his in his fight
over a position that he had at Emory, I
think, or was it was it Emory
>> at the York? They they renamed it, by
the way, Emory. Yes.
and and that whole thing is just a
tribute to him because he he maintained
his principles even when it meant even
when it meant that he would lose his job
and then when he lost his job he still
stuck to that and then his whole life
has been driven by it but it was driven
by it before he he even approached that
I mean that was the boldness of somebody
who had discovered that you know there
was a cure I forget what the what was
the condition that was it
>> cystic fibrosis Right.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And was it selenium?
That was the
>> selenium for that and selenium for
congestive heart failure. Oh, excuse me.
Selenium for hypertropic
cardiammyopathy.
>> Yeah. So, of course, they said he was a
nut because they all thought that these
things were genetic and they had no
explanation for it. That's why they said
it was genetic. But they just wouldn't
listen to a young man who had a bold
idea, but who had a lot of evidence to
support his position and had a lot of
proof in these autopsies and they just
dismissed him out of hand because he was
threatening their comfort zone. They had
developed their own research funding and
everything from this whole false
paradigm. It's the same way with cancer.
You know, we got this paradigm of cut,
poison, and burn. I was in a movie years
and years ago called Cup Poison and
Burn. And
>> that's right. I did see
>> I look completely different. I know. But
uh it's sad. But the reality is um that
whole paradigm is barbaric. It's
barbaric to think in the 21st century
that we still treat a disease like
cancer with these primitive modalities
of bombarding your body with toxic
substances that in and of themselves
could kill you and wiping out your whole
immune system on the theory that somehow
that taking away the cancer and good
cells is somehow going to result in your
rejuvenation and then giving you a bone
marrow transplant or doing something
heroic at the end. I mean, all these
things are it's just we we seem to be
not m far away from when in the Civil
War soldiers were brought into the
medical tents and they're they were
amputated
>> with with you know a little whiskey down
their throat and then they would saw off
a leg or an arm or whatever. We're we're
still in this very primitive mode and
cancer treatment is much like that.
Jonathan. Um um
we're gonna we're gonna allow Key to
unmute herself and ask question. Key is
going to keep it uh very brief. Also, um
Jonathan, just every time every time you
speak, every time a sentence comes out
of your mouth, different questions pop
in my head, but we don't we can't. So,
I'm just going to let Key
uh Key go right ahead. What's your
question? Hi Jonathan. Uh first and
foremost, I want to thank you for being
a patriot on behalf of humanity because
uh God sent the right warrior to come
along what I call Dr. Wallock, the
modern-day Moses. And that feat that
you've been fighting has been a gift to
all of us. So your life's work, I know
it's a calling and because you've been
blazing that trail for the greater good
and you truly we too truly honor you and
thank you. So
um in appreciation of all that um given
the last five years that we have
experienced given all of this medical
stuff happening
um there's not a three-letter agency
that really has any credibility in
reference to the government given the
fact that the government did not protect
us according to the right the rights
that were given to us by God. How is it
and what is your perspective on really
restoring sovereignty and trust and an
ethical ground to these health and
governance systems considered that the
dysfunction that they live with is one
that they're comfortable with?
>> So I I may be a fool but I am an
optimist and I I really at heart I am an
optimist. I do believe that the
principles that underly the constitution
and the unique nature of our republic in
defense of individual liberty and
sovereignty is so profound that uh we we
will ultimately return to the as Abraham
Lincoln put it the better angels of our
nature that um when when we're tempted
to go off on a fancy of socialism or
some ridiculous system that is
invariably a failure. Um, we learn
quickly that we're burnt uh we're burnt
by it, that we lose our rights, that
there there's great harm that comes to
us economically, personally, and uh and
it threatens the future of of coming
generations. Um, when those
circumstances arise, when for some
reason a pandemic leads us into a mental
fog that causes us to think that we're
in dire straits and there has to be some
dramatic thing tried or there's a great
depression that leads us in that
direction. Uh, as it did in the Great
Depression bringing socialism here. um
that uh that it leads us to confront
when we go down that path the horrors
that are associated with systems of
centralized government control that
deprive us of our freedom and what what
we have always is this original history.
That's why uh uh the socialists so
desperately tried to destroy our
original history by for example saying
that the country was not uh created in
but was created in the Jamestown colony
in 1617
uh and that we were founded on slavery
when in point of fact we were founded on
principles of liberty. Uh yes, we had
slavery in this country and yes, we we
did uh largely defeat the institution of
slavery even before the civil war when
the constitution itself was coming
about. Um the founding fathers were
committed to ending slavery. They
included a provision in the constitution
to end the fugitive slave trade which at
the time they created that provision was
the principal means by which slaves were
brought to America. And by the way, um
there were not only black slaves in
America, there were white slaves in
America. That's an untold story. There
were Irish slaves in America. And in
fact, um the Irish slaves came from a
penal colony. Uh they were they were
actually not a penal colony, but they
were uh from Oliver Cromwell's defeat of
the Irish in England. And they were the
cheapest on the auction block because
they didn't have to pay the costs of
bringing them from Africa and they were
captives. Well, Jonathan, I tell a story
and and and uh and I don't know if
you're making a distinction between
slaves. That's why I said we wanted to
have this conversation later. I don't
know if you're making a distinction
between slavery and indentured
servitude.
>> Yeah, I don't think there really is at
the time. So, in other words, at the
time. So in in um in 1614
in the Jamestown colony um there was a
uh slave Anthony I forget his last name
dog gone it he took the name of his a
slave owner he was uh black happened to
be black although at the time most of
the people who were indentured servants
he was an indentured servant but treated
like a slave and so were the whites
there were a majority of whites in the
colony at that time were indentured
servants. They were and and but this
this Anthony Johnson so he won his uh uh
master's approval for um to be set free.
So he was allowed to be have his
indenture terminated and he became free.
He then bought 20 acres of Virginia
farmland
and he enslaved uh 12 um black people.
They he could have had white people too,
but most of them were still under the
control of the original founders of the
Jamestown colony and created his own
profitable farm from that. But he
maintained the institution of slavery.
The point was that that was the way
agriculture was largely done at the
time. By the time of the Civil War in
1860,
the one of the largest slave owners in
Louisiana was Antoine Dub Clay. Antoine
Dub Clay was was black and he had over
200 black slaves under him. He was a
manumitted black slave. So the the whole
thing's so complicated because the
institution of slavery was such a part
of the economy. And by the way, um
Antoine Dublay married a white woman.
And you you would think based on you
know popular lore that that would have
been scandalous but it was not because
he was so wealthy from his massive
holdings.
He was accepted into the aristocracy in
Louisiana and when he married a white
woman it was just considered pass and
black's law dictionary would call a
different term for white anyway.
>> Right. Right. And but it's a complicated
thing and really the the whole notion of
um so by the time of the civil war there
were roughly 4 million black slaves.
There were uh very small number of white
slaves. There were something maybe maybe
150 200,000 white slaves in all of the
uh country but there were 4 million
black slaves. And that largely it became
a uh a a segregated institution. Slavery
did um with Bacon's starting with
Bacon's rebellion in Virginia
um when you had a slave uprising. And so
what they did is they created the
overseer type of system where they would
choose uh you you were fearful as a as a
slave owner that the slaves might over
you know have a revolution and kill you.
So you would hire overseers and they
began to distinguish based on race. So
they would hire white overseers over
black slaves. And this inculcated this
whole racist element that was
principally not present in the Jamestown
colony, but it became a feature of
slavery. By the time of the Civil War,
it was there obviously. And you know, so
anyway,
>> I tell I tell a story um to to your
point. Um in the smokeouses when they
were curing a tobacco, uh it was it was
written um one of these slave owners had
said, you know, why why do you put the
Irish guy in the smokehouse? And he
said, because they didn't want to waste
a good n-word,
>> right? And and actually in Barbados in
the sugar uh uh cane fields, it was
notorious that you know if you work the
sugar cane because it was just brutal
out there in the sun. It was also very
very labor intensive and people would
die in the fields. And uh there was a
preference for the Irish slave because
it was cheaper. So if you lost one, you
could afford it more than if you lost a
black slave. So you put the black slave
in, you know, you still see them in the
fields, but there were far less of them
by preference
um in favor of Irish slaves. But it's
all it's an economic institution. It's
horrible. Slavery is absolutely
horrific. We're all liberty. But the
point is that when you divorce, when you
create it in in a modern political
sense, you try to make it into a racist
construct,
uh, you lose the historicity, the truth
of the history. And I and I and I follow
you and and I do follow you and I do uh
think that it's it's difficult to put
our our glasses on uh or you know view
things from you know some things are
universal over time. You know uh you
wouldn't uh ar you know David is going
to arbitrate between the two or
Solomon's going to arbit arbitrate the
two between the two women and one
woman's going to say cut cut the baby in
half. Some things are universal, right?
Um
but um we have really uh enjoyed having
you on Daily with Doc. I know that
people's minds must be blown right now.
Um, Tom Chenalt says, "Uh, Jonathan, you
and Doc were a great team."
And, uh, all of these people on, uh,
YouTube are saying so many things. Olga
saying, "Children sold in the markets
along animals to look after the animals.
It still exists in in the Middle East.
Thanks, Mr. E-Mort."
Um, and, etc., etc.
and etc. Ruth Ellen, is there something
that you'd like to say to Jonathan
before we part?
Yes, I would.
Thank you so much, Jonathan, for coming
on and um sharing the information that
you've shared and giving us the link to
um the Arizona papers or I posted it
everywhere because it is our passion to
be able to speak freely about helping
and healing ourselves. And um I have no
words for my gratitude for what you do
and for you as a person. I've met you in
person several times and you're a very
good kind-hearted man. So, thank you.
>> Well, thank you very much and I want to
thank all of you for what you do because
you really are the hands and feet of Dr.
Wallak. Um, I think that uh that
essential nutritional message would
never have reached as many people as it
has all over the world without this
massive infusion of people who are
willing day in and day out to promote a
business that really, as I say, is more
about the health and welfare of the
people of the world than it is about the
profitability of any one man or one
person. Um, Dr. Wallak is uh an amazing
character and I think we all have a
rightful deep debt of gratitude to him
uh for what he has done. It it's been my
pleasure to have represented him uh over
the years and to have fought many a
legal battle on his behalf
>> and fortunately we've won many battles
and but those battles are are just a few
in the big scheme of things. We're going
to have to keep fighting for our
liberties for the rest of our lives and
for our children's lives and forever. As
you know, George Washington put it. Um
each new generation will have to
rekindle the sacred fire of liberty or
it will be extinguished. And um that's
certainly the case. It has pro been
proven over again and again. And we have
liberty only because we have the benefit
of those who have fought and died for
it. Um, and we will only have it in
future if people will continue to fight
and die for it.
>> Agreed. Agreed.
>> Uh, amazing. Jonathan, I know you didn't
expect that you would you would uh be
here this long with us. And if I had my
way, uh we'd probably be here hours more
because there's just we just scratched
the surface uh of the illustrious career
that you've you've had and uh continue
to have and the amount of body of work
that you uh do on behalf of the American
people. And uh we really appreciate you.
And I didn't even get to ask you a
political question, although you did a
really good job weaving in all the
answers. I I I really wanted to know
about Selenium and and and your
methodology and how much time it took
and and tons of other things, but I
never got to I never I really wanted to
know what made you run for Senate. I
don't know if we got a couple seconds to
kind of tell us that, but
>> Well, sure. So, um, in 2024,
I thought based on where we were as a
country, um, that if we had another four
years equivalent to what Joe Biden had
given us, that very surely um, our
nation would not survive. And so because
I again I'm driven by a love of the
Constitution and the founding principles
of this country um I knew it would be a
huge sacrifice and it was a big one for
my family. Um but I did it because I
thought it was necessary. I would never,
to tell you the truth, the last thing in
the world I would ever want to be is a
politician. But in a time of crisis,
that is the best thing to be because if
your country is going to go to hell in a
hand basket, you would better get there
fast enough before it actually gets to
hell. And and that means you got to get
in the position of being a able to hold
that basket. But as it turns out, it's
actually better for my family and for me
that I was not elected to the United
States Senate. And the reason is that uh
had I been elected there, um my
beautiful daughter who's now at the uh
Tish Academy or Tish uh Academy of Arts
or whatever it's called, School of Arts
at New York University and my son who's
entering uh George Mason University um
as a D1. So, he's going to there because
the D1 tennis school um and uh a lot of
our our extended family that needed us
would have had to have suffered uh
greatly because it just frankly um it's
>> doesn't pay well.
>> It doesn't and it's cost
it's a chronic cost. I mean, I I spent
uh a million dollars of my own resources
running for the US Senate.
>> That was a major sacrifice. Um, and I
and I did it willingly and so did my
wife and my kids because we all share
this love of the Constitution. I it
wasn't uh so unlike most politicians, as
I say, most politicians are running
because they can't do anything else. I
was leaving something that I did very
well um and had uh a lot of clients and
a lot of success uh to to save the
country and I thought it was essential.
I would never do it if I didn't think it
was essential. But fortunately, we have
not gone down that path. We didn't uh
continue the Biden administration's
um destruction of this nation. We've
started the reversal of that. I believe
in the end of this year, we're going to
see some major uptick in the economy.
But what we have seen is that we no
longer have an open border. We no longer
have a situation where uh uh the cartels
are destroying the cities in this
country with massive crime, sex
trafficking, drug trafficking. And uh we
no longer have a situation where those
who are engaged in pillaging this nation
in political positions of power are
doing it without having to watch their
back. Many of them are being prosecuted.
We have a situation where justice is
being reestablished. I just wished that
um you know we we uh we had gotten there
sooner because unfortunately
four years of what has happened to this
country under Joe Biden is leaving a
legacy that is going to last
generations.
Uh there are people who have, you know,
countless Americans have had um their
family members or lives taken as a
result of people here who came who had
criminal backgrounds who were not
vetted, just allowed straight in the
country. I went to the border. You can
probably still see the videos on
YouTube. I went to the border. I met
with the border patrol. Um, I went on a
patrol of the um, San Diego sector and I
I saw firsthand how they were just
coming through into this country. No
restriction whatsoever. They were taking
them to uh, tents where they were giving
them uh, uh, a free ride into this
country, literally connecting them with
NOS's that were paying for their
airfare, bus traffic, go anywhere in the
United States without ever having to
become an American citizen. Some 20
million Americans are 20 million people
are here in this country who've never
been asked to pledge allegiance to the
United States, never been asked to uh uh
do anything other than accept a welfare
check and who've never been asked to um
uh serve their country if necessary to
save it because this is not their
country. And there are many
>> Jonathan Jonathan there there's there's
there's good and bad in every
administration. I can remember
incessant buses
uh dropping off at different places in
New York and then when it became a
problem in New York, the buses would
drop off in New Jersey and then they
take the train in New York.
>> Yeah.
>> It was it was an incessant flow.
>> It's insane.
>> I couldn't tell you how long. It was it
was kind of it was kind of odd. It was
kind of odd.
>> Yeah. If you if you turn the wealth and
the privilege of being an American over
to the rest of the world, you shouldn't
be surprised when your destruction
follows.
And these things are among the things
that motivated me to get involved
because I I thought if I don't get
involved with this thing, I'm going to
really regret when I'm uh ready to pack
it in and go on to the next level that I
hadn't tried to do it. So trying to do
it was important for me mentally and
otherwise. I mean now I look back at it
and I say um I'm glad that I sacrificed
in order to try to save my country. I've
never Dr. Wallock served in the
military. I always seem to just miss
that uh by age. When I was at the
University of Illinois, um my roommate
worked for the newspaper and it's a
large college, 65,000 students. and on
April Fool's Day and I never knew what
day it was or time. Uh and it was on
April Fool's Day and uh he he set my
alarm real early in the morning so I'd
wake up, you know, super early. And then
uh and then he said, "Emort, look at the
paper." And I picked up the paper and it
was a April Fool's joke in the paper,
but it looked real and it said Reagan
calls for 60,000 troops to go to El
Salvador and it shows uh these people
troops landing on a beach head. And I
thought, "Wow, we're going to war." So I
picked up the phone. I called my dad who
was in the military for 30 38 years. And
I said, "What service should I go into,
Dad, to for this war in El Salvador?"
And he said, "What are you talking
about?" said, "No war in El Salvador."
And I said, 'Yeah, Dad. Look at the
newspaper. I said, 'What what should I
go into? He said, 'Look, don't be don't
be a fool. Don't don't don't uh put your
life in direct harm's way. Will you take
the best thing you can do is go into the
Air Force or worse, go go go to the
Navy. So, I said, "All right." So, then
I went over to the recruiting station on
the campus. And I walk in there and
somebody takes a picture of me. I
thought, "That's weird." I go over to
the recruiting officer. I get in there
and sit down at a desk and he said,
"Okay, well, you know, you got to fill
out these forms and we can we can get
you into the ROC program here at the
university." I said, "I don't want to go
through ROTC. I want to go I want to go
to El Salvador and fight the whatever
the communists are down there." And he
said, "There's what are you talking
about El Salvador? There's no war in El
Salvador." Then it dawned on me, uh oh,
>> and then I was uh they called me the
biggest fool on campus. They had me in
the newspaper.
>> They took the picture. That's great.
idiot went volunteer for
>> That's great. That's great. You just you
just offended Andy, a Navy man. And and
uh and um who else we have that's a
Navy? Uh um
>> Ivon's Navy.
>> My my dad's view he was in the Air
Force. So his he was in the Navy
actually in the beginning. He he was in
the in the Navy. Then he was in
recommissioned in the Army Airore. And
then the Army Airore became the Air
Force and then he was in the Air Force.
Um that that picture you see right
there, that's my dad. Um he the
pseudonym Tommy Raren.
>> That's your dad.
>> My dad. He fought 61 PROFESSIONALS.
>> I KNOW WHO HE IS.
>> There you go. So he he was an incredibly
strong and fantastic
>> Oh.
>> But he was in the he was the boxing
coach for the Air Force. Uh, but he
loved the Air Force and he wanted me to
go into the if I went in, he wanted me
to go into the Air Force first and then
if not that, then the Navy, but he
didn't. His brother had been uh at
Buganville in World War II and was blown
apart in the Marines. Uh, and then he he
came back to the States and was stitched
together and then he insisted on
reinlisting, went back and fought in
World War II again, was blown up again
somewhere. Uh, but he didn't want that
same fate, I think, for his son. So he
uh anyway he had he had a bad idea about
the Marines and the Army from that. But
>> I gather he might. Andy, do you want to
>> do you want to chime in?
>> Go ahead.
>> Oh, I didn't Oh, okay. Uh Andy gets a
chance. Thank you. You're very very
gracious. You were speaking earlier
about the founding fathers and I love
the term brilliant which represents
light and they truly as men are
brilliant their command of the English
language
and in that the command and the
understanding about human behavior
especially with regards about power and
how the constitution was created and
then incorporated a bill of rights to
protect protectors from the very
government constitution created. So it
was the people that were there with the
intent. My question is this. Is there
currently
anyone in the judiciary in particular in
the Supreme Court is even close to the
brilliance of our founding fathers that
you know of?
>> Well, that's a tall order, I think. Um I
>> Leave it to me. Yeah, leave it to me.
Yeah,
>> I I think
there are brilliant justices on the
Supreme Court, some not so,
>> but uh I think Gorsuch is great. I think
uh they're very intelligent people. I I
I just um uh there are people outside of
the Supreme Court that I think are um
right up there. Um there's uh uh Phil
Hamburger who's who wrote the book uh is
the administrative state um
constitutional or something like that.
And uh he he's a genius I think. Uh and
there are certain other people. I think
um Paul Clement who was a former
solicitor general of the United States
and who argued the Obamacare case before
the Supreme Court. I think he's one of
the most articulate and brilliant um
minds in the law. Uh but to your point
um you're if you study the words of the
founding fathers you come away with that
impression that you have that these
people were brilliant
>> brilliant
>> and they really were a select group that
uh it's remarkable it's actually divine
I think that they were
>> it is truly god-given
>> and so on the issue of power um George
Washington said let there be no change
by usurpation he was referring to uh
changing the Constitution. Let there be
no change by usurppation. For though in
one instance it may be an instrument of
good, it is the customary weapon by
which free governments are destroyed. Um
always a remarkable statement. Uh
Jefferson said um I am not a friend to a
very energetic government. It is always
oppressive.
um they were they were aware that the
product of their their hands and minds
um the Constitution of the United States
was a a precarious thing. Uh James
Madison referred to it as a mere
parchment barrier that only if people
who were in power uh respected the
Constitution's limits on their power
could the republic be maintained. But if
they didn't respect those limits, then
uh we would be destroyed. And so
Jefferson thought that you had to bleed
the tree of liberty. He said, every 14
years, in other words, have a revolution
in the United States every 14 years to
restore the balance of of power in favor
of individual liberty because people
would invariably seize uh positions of
power, be elected to office, and would
use it for their own self-interest.
So um that's always it's always the
issue uh whether we are allowing those
that represent us to assume power beyond
the constitution's limits risking the
loss of the republic. And we have uh you
know it's interesting the constitution
prevents the states and localities from
uh changing from a republican form of
government. Constitution itself
guarantees a republican form of
government uh in the states and
localities. Not only that, the
constitution requires an oath to the con
support the constitution by every
elected officer whether in the federal
government or in the states. So, uh,
technically speaking, someone like, um,
Ilhan Omar or, uh, AOC, who are
socialists, self-avoued socialists,
um, are ineligible to be seated in
Congress if you abide by the
Constitution because they can't
truthfully they can't truthfully swear
the constitutionally required oath to
support the Constitution because they're
on public record as favoring its
destruction. American Socialist Party
believes in the destruction of the
Constitution.
>> And so, in other words, if we had kept
ourselves aligned with the founding
fathers, we wouldn't have had um
individuals like that who could a vote.
They would be potentially elected, but
they couldn't be seated. They couldn't
swear that oath. That oath was designed.
There's some 13 provisions of the
constitution that carry with it
restrictions to ensure the perpetuation
of the republican form of government.
So we can never become it's not just
that you know President Trump said um
America will never be a socialist
nation. We will never uh the people will
not agree to it. Um
well in fact the Constitution of the
United States forbids it because it it
it requires adherence to the Republican
form of government.
>> We are listening to we are listening to
brilliance right now.
>> Well yeah the guy
>> Thank you. Thank you. The guy definitely
readers are always leaders,
you know. He and he is definitely a
leader and we appreciate you being here,
Jonathan.
>> Well, everybody's got to go. I I've
ruined your whole afternoon.
>> On the contrary,
>> man, not not not at all. You you've en
enlightened our afternoon and um uh
given us all some things to think about
and appreciate. So uh we we do
appreciate uh everything that you've
said and uh we have on the screen our
good friend Jonathan Eort and if you are
not on the screen do uh show him some
appreciation because we we we do
appreciate that you were here with us
today and we have our good friend uh and
the co-executive producer Ruth Ellen
Sanchez
uh who is manning the team as uh Becca
has taken a day or two off. I'm coach AJ
on the screen. We have Phyllis and Andy
Anderson who are pioneers in longevity.
Known Jonathan for a year or two. And we
have Marilyn Pazera Spear who is typing
away trying to keep up with all this
constitutional wisdom that has been
expoused today. And we have Mary who is
bringing questions uh and and taming
people from trying to take over the show
with all of their wild questions. And
speaking of tame and wild, we have our
own personal zoologologist
uh Albert down in South Africa who for
uh breakfast wrestles lions. So we are
proud that Albert is with us today and
all of you who are watching uh out on
Rumble and Facebook and YouTube uh we
thank you very much and Ruth Ellen take
us out.
>> Thank you everybody. Also if you were
referred to this program by anybody
please make sure to get back with them
as they will be your primary support.
Um, if you have questions, you can email
us at questions@ailywoodsdoc.com.
Also, we have a phone team, so you can
speak to a certified holistic health
coach and that is 855-9493377.
Also, per the FDA,
this program was for educational
purposes only, not meant to treat,
diagnose, cure any diseases. And um we
just want to thank Jonathan, our
favorite constitutional lawyer. And
Jonathan, my son would love to talk to
you because he is a constitutionalist
at his true core.
So thank you everyone and have a
beautiful day. And always remember to be
kind. Be kind because you don't know
what somebody is going through
and sometimes you will never know. So
just be good. Thank you everybody. Have
a great day.
>> Take care.
>> Thank you Jonathan.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. [music]
Testimonials are shared as individual
experiences of the individual. Results
vary and may not be typical. We do not
make any claims regarding [music] health
or income. As an empowered individual,
you do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics. [music] Dr. Joel
Wallik, bachelor of science and plant
and soil sciences, doctor of veterary
medicine, four post-doates and
pathology, naturopathic doctor.
>> [music]
>> This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
[music] the individual. Results vary and
may not be typical. We do not make any
claims regarding [music] health or
income. As an empowered individual, you
do have options available. We are
honored to continue to share the
teachings of a founding father of the
science of epigenetics. Dr. Joel Wallik,
bachelor [music] of science and plant
and soil sciences, doctor of veterary
medicine, for post-doates and pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not